Herkese merhaba arkadaşlar Almanca kolay
hoşgeldiniz Ben Almanca öğretmeni Erhan
Özdemir a1 a2 ders videolarının ilki ile
karşınızdayım Bu dersimizde arkadaşlar
selamlaşma vedalaşma kalıplarını görüyor
olacağız ancak Kendi kendinize şunu
sorabilirsiniz neden alfabeyle
başlamadık Neden Çünkü arkadaşlar
Almanca Tıpkı güzel türkçemizde olduğu
gibi aynı şekilde telaffuz ediliyor yani
Adem iş oluyorum bir biliyorum bunları
zaten ayrıntılı şekilde alfabe konusunda
görüyor olacağız Tabii ki farklılıklar
var belli başlı harfler yangına
geldiğinde farklı telaffuz ediliyor
dediğim gibi bunları ayrıntılı şekilde
görüyor olacağız alfabe konusunda
buradaysa selamlaşma vedalaşma
kalıplarını ayrıntılı şekilde görüyor
olacağız Hazırsanız dersimiz başlasın
buraya baktığımızda arkadaşlar Hello
hı Hello merhaba demek Evet ki Halo
merhaba demekmiş bu Mazlum bunu maden
sabah bu Cumanın İyi sabahlar
farkettiyseniz arkadaşlar gu tennogen
Demedim bugün malum dedim demek ki ve ee
be Neyi bir arada gördüğümde ne
yapıyormuşum özellikle kelimenin sonunda
ise Gun şeklinde yorum diyorum
Dolayısıyla günü malum Grup macun
günaydın demek bu genellikle arkadaşlar
Almanya'da sabah saatleri ve altı
itibariyle Saat dokuza kadar
söyleyebilirsiniz tabi 9'dan sonra
söylediğinizde size tuhaf bakabilirler
bu sebepler artık güne geçmiş oluyoruz
değil mi Demek ki sabah saatlerinde
ediyor musunuz bugün malum demiş
oluyoruz değil mi bugün tak tak tak ara
o gün demek bu Nihat bu durumda ne
oluyor İyi günler değil mi Bu intihar
iyi günler Bu da genellikle arkadaşlar
işte Saat ondan itibaren kaça kadar
söyleyebiliriz herhalde bir saat 16'ya
17'ye kadar rahatlıkla söyleyebiliriz
bunun Tak bu iltihak Demek ki neymiş İyi
günler demekmiş buraya baktığımızda bu
and and abroad akşam demek Arkadaşlar bu
durumda ne olacak bu günahın Yiğit
akşamlar değil mi İyi akşamlar bu
genellikle 17 20'ye kadar Evet 17-20
arası bugün abi iyi akşamlar diyebiliriz
bu güzel Türkçede öyle Öyle değil mi bu
günahımız Bu saatler için iyi akşamlar
diyebiliriz Evet Bu tenerte utherna
farkettiyseniz arkadaşlar CHP Hey bir
arada gördüğümde a
O söylemiş olduğum gibi alfabe konusunda
çok ayrıntılı şekilde gülü olacağız cvh
Demek ki bir arada kullanıldığında asla
cvh demeyelim sihad ile naht naht orada
bir ve hırıltılı bir hevar naht gece
demek farkettiyseniz burada Arkadaşlar
bu ten Ah dedim ancak diğerlerinde ne
vardı bu ten oradaki en harfi kalkmış
oluyor bunun sebebi ne bunu sebebi
Arkadaşlar artık Alo artikeller konusunu
Okan ayrıntılı şekilde günü olacağız ki
otomatik bir şekilde bunu kavrıyor
olacaksınız Arkadaşlar bu sebepten adım
adım gidiyoruz Sakin bir şekilde
ilerliyoruz ve Şundan emin olun
öğreneceksiniz arkadaşlar kolay bir
şekilde öğreneceksiniz Şimdi burada bu
tenerte demem gerekiyor şimdiden
söylemiş olayım Nah bunu artık
ne olduğundan dolayı buradaki N harfi
düşmüş oluyor Dediğim gibi ayrıntılı
şekilde göreceğiz iyi geceler
dediğimizde bunu saat 20 den itibaren
bir ve söyleyebilir sanki 20 21 den
itibaren Bu ternat demek ki iyi geceler
demekmiş geçelim sağ tarafa arkadaşlar
Evet burada birazcık uzun bir kelime var
avuf vida Simav bileziğin Arkadaşlar
orada bir göz konu çizmeye çalıştım
vibez einziehen demedim farkettiyseniz
Zin dedim demek ki evet Neyi ne
yapıyorum Bir bir arada kullanmış
oluyorum Dolayısıyla of bir zihin bir
şey daha var iyi ve eyyy ilan artan
değil mi bir arada kullanırken diye
derzin demedim denedim mide zemin dedim
Bunu da zaten alfabe konusunda görüyor
olacağız tekrar
eve gitmek üzere dedim tekrar görüşmek
üzere de orada bir göz ikonu çizdim
neden zil görmek demek arkadaşlar görmek
bakmak zihan vida tekrar Dolayısıyla
tekrar görüşmek üzere diyecek olursa
Almanca'da av with Azim demiş oluyor ve
tekrar görüşmek üzere Demek ki o ilgili
kişi Karşımda ysa bir göz kontağı varsa
bir göz iletişimi varsa ne yapıyormuşuz
alvida Sen gidiyor muyuz bakın bir
altında aofi Dayan ve telefon çizmeye
çalıştım Evet oradaki telefon hıh en
duymak işitmek anlamında arkadaşlar Of
video Uyan Demek ki güzel Türkçe birebir
çevirecek olursak tekrar duymak üzere
Tabii öyle de miyiz ne deriz tekrar
görüşmek üzere Deniz ancak Almanca'da
telefonda Eğer kişiyle vedalaşıyor
samoff ilah Önderim Yani tek
da görüşmek üzere anlamına gelmiş oluyor
Dolayısıyla bakın buradaki höhen ya da
herhalde yine neymiş duymak işitmek
demekmiş tekrar görüşmek üzere anlamına
gelen Demek ki of videoya telefonda
bulanıyor Muş Biz belt biz styled
Yakında görüşmek üzere anlamında
Arkadaşlar biz ibaret Demek ki bu da
gene bir vedalaşma şekli bir Siper et ve
sonuncu kelimeyi baktığımızda çöz ya da
Tüh şeklinde de söyle ne biliyor
farkettiyseniz arkadaşlar tsc ve
harflerini bir araya getirdiğinde güzel
Türkçemizdeki Ç harfi ne denk düşmüş
oluyor ve çöz demiş oluyoruz bu yazımı
ile alakalı Arkadaşlar en sondaki seneye
baktığımızda onu 2s şekli
Evet yazabiliyoruz Beta işareti ile de
yazılabilen eski kaynaklar var Ancak en
en güncel haliyle Almanca sürekli
güncellenen bir dil olduğu için en son
haliyle en son yazım kurallarına göre bu
bu şekilde yazılmış oluyor Dolayısıyla
çöz Bye bye anlamında kullanılabilir
güzel Türkçeye çevireceğim Dilerseniz bu
öğrenmiş olduğumuz selamlaşma vedalaşma
kılıfların şöyle bir üzerinden geçelim
Hello mu demek ki Hello miniş Arkadaşlar
merhaba demekmiş Halo
Ahmet kurter maden ya da Anlaşılır olsun
diye bu ter muayenede vurguluyorum artık
ile ediyorum Utku Magnum Magnum Günaydın
demekmiş bunun Malum bu Evet takmayla
arkadaşlar gün demekte Dolayısıyla bu
iltihak İyi günler anlamına gelmiş
oluyor değil mi bugün ahmet' abim neymiş
Ağabey akşam değil mi Adam Belki
hatırlayabiliriz bunu bu günahımız Demek
ki İyi akşamlar demekmiş bu tırnağı Bu
tennar demek ki Nah gece bu telefon
verildiğinde İyi geceler dinliyormuş
ancak burada neyi dikkat etmemiz
gerekiyor en harfi yok değil mi
diğerlerinde varken burada bu ten Ah ne
oluyor düşmüş oluyor
bu vedalaşmaya baktığımızda ysa Evet
gözü konuyla işaretledim bunu av bir
zihin africa's in Tekrar görüşmek üzere
anlamına gelen o fidesinin video ne
dedik arkadaşlar Tekrar zihin görme kafi
dazin tekrar görüşmek üzere anlamına
geliyormuş ve telefon konuyla
işaretlemiş olduğum of mi da arayabilme
hem anneydi dinlemek duymak işitmek
değil mi vida tekrar duymak üzere Tabii
ki güzel türkçemizde öyle demiyoruz ne
diyoruz tekrar görüşmek üzere ediyoruz
Bunu telefonda da söylüyoruz ancak
Almanca'da Avni davran deniyormuş tekrar
görüşmek üzere diyecek olursak ya da
düzeltiyorum Yakında görüşmek üzere Biz
Art Biz bel Yakında görüşmek üzere an
bu ve vay vay denildiğinde ne diyor
musunuz çöz ya da 12 üye uzatıyor
biliyoruz Ve Türküz diyebiliyoruz
Dilerseniz bu görmüş olduklarımızı doğru
telafi hızıyla tekrarlayalım şunu da
hatırlatmakta fayda var arkadaşlar
derslerimizde Bundan böyle her öğrenmiş
olduğumuzu tekrar bir üzerinden geçmek
üzere telaffuz çalışmasını yapıyor
olacağız Hazırsanız telaffuz çalışmamız
başlasın
bu halo halo grubum var
en uygun mal
bu kurgu ta
Bu grupta
biz buna Ahmet
ne günahım
bu gudina
Ama bu günler
bu Audi bebeğin
bu audilerin
bu Audi Dayan
o Afrika yani
ama biz Birds
ama biz byte
bu çöz
bu dersimizin Sonuna Geldik Arkadaşlar
bu dersimizde selamlaşma vedalaşma
kalıplarıyla sizlere merhaba demiş olduk
derslerimizi takip etmemiz için
arkadaşlar abone olmanızı tavsiye
ediyorum sonraki dersimizde görüşmek
üzere diyorum Hoşçakalın tüm söz